welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness is set to take us on the
craziest wall-shattering journey through
the mcu multiverse as doctor strange
sorcerer supreme wrong and the
all-powerful scarlet witch look to
potentially face off against the dark
and scary threats that lurk beyond
what's known but with the stakes this
high in the multiverse in the balance
not even having professor xavier from
the fox x-men is going to be enough
because if things are about to get dark
the mcu is going to need a hero for the
end of the night but she's gotta be
strong and she's gotta be fast she's
gotta be fresh from the fight i'm
talking about the long-awaited america
chavez baby but just who is sochi
gomez's america chavez in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness well i'm
gonna give you the lowdown on just who
mcu's newest young avenger is so that
you can get an idea of just how
massively an important role that america
chavez is going to play in the upcoming
multiverse mayhem so when america chavez
or miss america first made her debut on
the pages of 2011's vengeance number one
she was already pretty much straight out
of the gate one of the most powerful
marvel heroes in the comic book
multiverse as creators joe casey and
nick dragada equipped america chavez
with crazy amounts of super human
strength and durability so much so that
she can freaking rip a zillion ton metal
door off of its hinges like it was
nothing and produce a stomp so powerful
that could send even asgardian gods
flying with kid loki even referring to
america chavez as a nearly
indestructible superwoman who can throw
tanks to the moon out of fear of getting
his ass cheeks beat which was very much
on the table and loki is 100 correct
about that nearly indestructible part
with america being able to deflect
bullets and even energy blasts with
relative ease and hell in vengeance
number five america chavez even
withstood multiple dragon ball z level
magical blasts from the sorcerer supreme
of the sixth dimension tiboro that
instantly incinerated the far less
durable humans all around her so it
definitely makes sense that mcu america
chavez seems pretty confident enough to
take a big leap and a swing at wanda
maximoff here at this moment in the
trailer as this huge surge of clashing
energy blasts seems to happen right
after america leaps off of an altar
designed suspiciously similar to the
scarlet witch entry in the darkhold
something i pointed out on mytwitter.com
come join me on twitter.com if you want
to see me tweet some weird theories and
stuff and hey the reason why mcu america
chavez can jump that high in the trailer
in the first place is because in the
comics she can literally fly super fast
and even effortlessly fly within the
vacuum of space without the need of
oxygen but while all of these powers are
super dope the most notable and exciting
of all of america chava's abilities is
her ability to create star-shaped
portals to literally anywhere that she
feels like going in the marvel
multiverse at will anytime anywhere and
this is why we see this phenomenal piece
of sam raimi imagery of doctor strange
being sucked into this star-shaped
portal because that right there is
america chinavas baby and she does this
quite often traveling the marvel
multiverse looking for universes that
have bad guys that are in desperate need
of getting punched by a super powered
puerto rican this right here is the game
changer because with america chavez now
a player in the mcu we don't need forces
like doctor strange or the tva being our
only gateways to the multiverse because
for years before she ever even joined up
with the young avengers in the comics
america chavez has been using her innate
cosmic awareness of the multiverse in
conjunction with all of these amazing
powers to sort of be the captain marvel
of the multiverse and has even been
referred to as the paramedic for the
multiverse in the comics you know kind
of like doctor strange will have to be
for the mcu multiverse and likely how
their paths will end up crisscrossing in
the movie but hey how the hell did
america chavez get these powers anyway
well for the longest time it was
believed even to america chavez herself
that she originally hailed from an
alternate female-dominated paradise
universe outside of the marvel
multiverse called the utopian parallel
as the daughter of the superhero
brothers amalia and elena chavez and all
the women and girls of the utopian
parallel apparently were all blessed
with very similar powers to america
chavez thanks to the all-powerful
benevolent god of their universe that
they called the demiurge now america
thought she decided to leave this
utopian paradise for other universes
after her mother's died protecting her
original reality basically protecting
other realities in their honor but
apparently according to a recent 2021
america chavez series called america
chavez made in the usa that was all
[ __ ] all those years of america
chavez telling everybody on the young
avengers in the world that she was from
this utopian universe of super powered
women was actually just america chavez
repressing her true tragic origin
because apparently america chavez and
her forgotten sister catalina chavez
were actually from the bronx but were
also born with a super awful genetic
disease called edges syndrome so in a
desperate attempt to save their
daughters their mothers amalia chavez a
super smart microbiologist and elena
chavez a super smart pathologist did
probably the one dumb thing that they've
probably done in their super smart lives
by having their daughter subjected to
weird experimentations with extra
dimensional energies along with other
girls around the world with edge
syndrome on this private island that was
called the utopian parallel by the super
sketchy billionaire island-owning
scientist called mr gales and it turns
out mr gales uh not a good dude so when
america and catalina's mothers discover
that mr gales wants to use the powers
that america got from her experimental
treatments for his own ends america's
mother amalia sacrifices her own life to
free all the experimented on little
girls and destroy the facility and then
elena chavez loses her life not long
after trying to help america and
catalina escape specifically by being
shot by mr gales himself and ripping
america's younger sister catalina away
from america completely so the trauma of
experiencing all of that in a really
short period of time at the tender age
of five caused america chavez to repress
all of these bad memories basically just
over exaggerate the good parts of her
memory creating this entire fantasy
about a demiurge and superpowered moms
from another dimension and although
america chavez has been a badass
unstoppable woman for years now that her
edges syndrome has recently started to
manifest in the comics her powers have
now been basically reduced by half with
her now being unable to fly or
multiverse hop for more than five
minutes at a time but that all being
said after being adopted by the santana
family of washington heights and living
with them until her teenage years miss
america would then go on to join the
superhero teams the team brigade the
team that she was on when she first
debuted in the vengeance comics the
young avengers alongside kate bishop
hawkeye marvel boy wiccan hulkling and a
kid loki in 2013's young avengers number
5 and even helped out her bestie kate
bishop on the west coast avengers in
2018 but that is a super condensed
slowdown of everything that you gotta
know about america chavez leading up to
this amazing film that is going to be
doctor strange and the multiverse and
madness what are you most excited about
to see from america chavez and what do
you want to see the mcu do with america
chavez down the road like i want to see
america chavez just interact with the
90s x-men because that would be really
dope thank you guys so much for watching
this video you can follow me at mass
entertainment if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and if
you do on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and also make sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get really
fun doctor strange the multiverse of
madness gear but anyways thank you guys
again for watching and i'll see you guys
later goodbye
[Music]
you